[MUSIC]
SPEAKER: How much money should be
spent on reducing air pollution?
The US Environmental
Protection Agency, the EPA,
tried to answer this question
with a cost-benefit analysis.
It asked, how many lives
would be saved by cleaner air,
and how much was each life worth?
It set the value of
a life at $3.7 million,
except for people older
than 70, whose lives it
valued at only $2.3 million dollars.
Lying behind the different
valuations was a utilitarian idea.
Saving an old person's
life produces less utility
than saving a young person's life
because the young person has longer
to live, and therefore, more
happiness still to enjoy.
Advocates for the elderly did not agree.
They protested what they called
the senior citizen discount.
What do you think?
Was the agency right or wrong to
assign a monetary value to human life?
[MUSIC]